THE HOUR ON THE VERY SCARY
STORY AS PART OF TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
MAJOR DEVELOPMENTS.
THIS IS A BIG NIGHT TONIGHT IN
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
NOW THE BIG BREAKING NEWS, THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE HAS NOW
ENDED WHAT HAS BEEN A 14-MONTH
INVESTIGATION IN THIS PHASE OF
THE RUSSIAN PROBE.
IS STARTING TO RELEASE DETAILS
OF WHAT IT HAS UNCOVERED.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE ON
COLLUSION.
WE STILL HAVE FISA ABUSE,
URANIUM ONE, UNMASKING SCANDAL
AND THE CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER.
THIS IS NOT INCLUDED TONIGHT.
THE TAKE-AWAY FROM THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE ZERO
EVIDENCE -- LET ME REPEAT.
NONE.
NO EVIDENCE SHOWING COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
RUSSIA.
I HOPE ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS
MERRY BAND OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTISANS AND DONORS AND WITCH
HUNTERS ARE ALL WATCHING
TONIGHT.
THEIR INVESTIGATION SHOULD BE
SHUT DOWN IMMEDIATELY.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
ROD ROSENSTEIN NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
WE WILL EXPLAIN THAT.
HE IS RUSHING TO MUELLER'S
DEFENSE SAYING THAT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS "NOT AN
UNGUIDED MISSILE."
ROSENSTEIN IS TRYING TO COVER
HIMSELF BECAUSE THE NEW
INFORMATION PROVES THAT
MUELLER IS IN AND HAS BEEN IN
A GIANT WITCH HUNT.
ALSO TONIGHT THE MEDIA, THE
DEMOCRATS, THIS IS WHAT YOU
HAVE TO TAKE AWAY FROM THIS.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
NEARLY 18 MONTHS.
THEY HAVE PERPETUATED ONE OF
THE BIGGEST HOAXES IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
WE'LL HAVE MORE IN A MINUTE.
HEAR THIS.
OTHER KEY FINDINGS FROM THE
MEMBERS ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, THERE IS A PATTERN
OF RUSSIAN ATTACK AGAINST
AMERICA'S KEY ALLIES IN
EUROPE.
RUSSIAN HACKERS USE SOCIAL
MEDIA.
IN 2015, 2016 AS WELL HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU TO SOW
POLITICAL DISCORD IN THE
UNITED STATES.
OBAMA DID NOTHING TO STOP THIS
THOUGH HE WAS WARNED IT WAS
HAPPENING.
THE COMMITTEE AGREES WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OVERALL
ASSESSMENT ON THE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE AND THEY FIND
PREFERENCE FOR CANDIDATE
DONALD TRUMP.
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS ARE
ALSO MAKING VERY CLEAR -- THIS
PART IS IMPORTANT -- THE ONLY
PART OF THE INVESTIGATION THAT
IS CLOSED REGARDING RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THAT IS IT.
THEY WILL STILL BE PROBING
WHAT IS UNRESOLVED ISSUE WITH
FISA ABUSES AND THE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
SARA CARTER WILL JOIN US
REPORTING AND THE OTHER
SOURCES ARE CONFIRMING TO THE
SHOW AN EXPLOSIVE REVELATION
ABOUT THE FORMER OBAMA FORMER
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JAMES CLAPPER WHO
ALLEGEDLY LEAKED TO FAKE NEWS
CNN THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS
BRIEFED ABOUT THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT CLAPPER
WAS IN CONTACT WITH TAPPER AT
THE SAME TIME THAT CNN
PUBLISHED REPORT ABOUT
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT OBAMA BEING BRIEFED
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
IF YOU WILL REMEMBER, THIS
CREATED A HUGE MASSIVE
FIRESTORM.
THIS LED TO THE BREATHLESS
TRUMP CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN PUSHING EVER
SINCE.
SOURCES ARE TELLING US TONIGHT
THAT CLAPPER WAS EITHER CNNS
ORIGINAL SOURCE OR THE CON
PERSONALLING SOURCE ABOUT THE
REPORT ON THE DOSSIER.
WHAT IS EVEN MORE PATHETIC AND
MORE SLEAZY IS THAT AFTER
ALLEGEDLY LEAKING INFORMATION
TO CNN, WELL, CLAPPER THEN PUT
OUT A STATEMENT IN JANUARY OF
2017 THAT READS IN PART THIS
EVERYTHING I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP TO
DISCUSS RECENT MEDIA REPORTS
ABOUT OUR BRIEFING LAST
FRIDAY.
I EXPRESS MY PROFOUND DISMAY
AT THE LEAKS THAT HAVE BEEN
APPEARING IN THE PRESS.
WE BOTH AGREE THEY ARE EXTREME
LIQUOR ROSEIVE AND DAMAGE --
EXTREMELY CORROSIVE AND
DAMAGING TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
CLAPPER WAS LYING TO HIS
TEETH.
HE WAS ONE OF THE LEAKERS.
SINCE THEN THE FORMER DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE HAS
BEEN DOING EVERYTHING AND
ANYTHING POSSIBLE TO PROP UP
THE PHONY CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR DOSSIER.
WATCH THIS.
>> WITH RESPECT TO THE DOSSIER
ITSELF, THE KEY THING IS IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHO PAID FOR
IT.
IT'S WHAT THE DOSSIER SAID AND
THEY THE EXTENT OF WHICH IS
CORROBORATED OR NOT.
>> Sean: WE REACHED OUT TO
JAMES CLAPPER FOR A STATEMENT.
HE WORKS FOR FAKE NEWS CNN ON
SARA'S REPORT AND HIS
SPOKESPERSON DECLINED TO
COMMENT BUT HE NOTED IT
APPEARS TO BE ABOUT LEAKING
INFORMATION THAT WAS NOT
CLASSIFIED OR SENSITIVE.
SO CLAPPER IS NOT OUTRIGHT
DENYING IT WHICH TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW.
WE HAVE FOR OVER A YEAR BEEN
OUT HERE AN ISLAND TO
OURSELVES AS WE HAVE BEEN
UNCOVERING THIS SCANDAL AND
TELLING YOU AS SHOCKING AS
WHAT IS BEING EXPOSED IS ONLY
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, 14 MONTHS, STILL
CONDUCTING VERY IMPORTANT
INVESTIGATION.
THEY HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT THEY DO HAVE TO DO WITH
UNMASKING AT AN UNPRECEDENTED
LEVEL OF THE FISA LAW AND FISA
ABUSES AND THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR FAKE NEWS
DOSSIER.
THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
YOU HAVE BEEN LIED TO FOR OVER
A YEAR.
NOW TO THE OTHER KEY FINDINGS
FROM THE REPUBLICANS ON THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
THEY PROVE WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU FOR OVER A YEAR
THAT THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS LIED TO YOU.
THERE IS NO TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
DISGRACEFUL COVERAGE AS MEANS
OF REMEMBERING WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING.
>> A DIZZYING 24 HOURS IN THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
NO LONGER JUST INCHING TOWARD
THE PRESIDENT, THIS MORNING
IT'S MORE LIKELY CAREENING.
>> I THINK THIS IS POTENTIALLY
MORE DANGEROUS SITUATION THAN
WATERGATE.
WE ARE AT A VERY DANGEROUS
MOMENT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM DURING ELECTION
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER TO
UNDERMINE THE BASIS OF OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS AFRAID.
POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
THERE AT SEA FOR HIM.
WE WILL CALL IT "HURRICANE
VLADIMIR" IF YOU WILL.
THE RUSSIAN THING.
>> THIS IS OUTRIGHT TREASON.
THERE IS NO QUESTION WHAT HE
IS DOING IS GIVING AID AND
COMFORT TO THE ENEMY.
>> THEY SAID ELECTION HACKING
IS AT THE CALIBER OF A PRO
HARBOR OR 9/11.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT
THE THRESHOLD OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: THE ONLY THING THAT
HAD ANYTHING TO DO RUSSIA WAS
HILLARY.
HER BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
ANYONE WITH HALF A BRAIN COULD
SEE THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
NOW TONIGHT THE MEDIA IN THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD BE APOLOGIZING
TO YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR
PREDDING OUTRIGHT LIE --
SPREADING OUTRIGHT LIES,
MISINFORMATION AND PROPAGANDA
FOR A YEAR.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN THE SAME
BOAT OF THE MEDIA.
THEY LOOK LIKE COMPLETE AND
TOTAL AND UTTER FOOLS TONIGHT.
LEADING THE WAY IS THE RANKING
DEMOCRAT ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
THAT WOULD BE CONGRESSMEN I
WANT TO WORK AT FAKE NEWS
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC ADAM
SCHIFF.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS PAINFUL
AND THIS PATHETIC EVOLUTION ON
THE SO-CALLED TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION WE NOW KNOW NEVER
HAPPENED AND DOESN'T EXIST.
>> CHRIS, UNFORTUNATELY, I
CAN'T GO INTO THE EVIDENCE.
>> YOU HAD SOMETHING HARD THAT
YOU CAN'T REVEAL?
>> I CAN'T REVEAL THAT, CHRIS.
>> OF COURSE, THERE IS ONE
THING TO SAY THERE IS
EVIDENCE.
THERE IS ANOTHER THING TO SAY
WE CAN PROVE THIS OR PROVE IT
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT OR
THERE IS ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
BRING TO A GRAND JURY FOR
PURPOSES OF CRIMINAL
INDICTMENT.
>> I DON'T THINK WE CAN SAY
ANYTHING DEFINITIVELY AT THIS
POINT.
WE ARE STILL AT THE VERY EARLY
STAGE OF THE INVESTIGATION.
>> LAST MARCH, YOU SAID YOU
HAD MORE THAN CIRCUMSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE OF TREASONS YOU
COLLUSION WITHSH TREASONOUS
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA.
BE SPECIFIC.
I THINK AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT
TO KNOW A YEAR LATER WHAT THAT
IS.
>> I CERTAINLY SAID THAT THERE
IS AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSIONMENT I NEVER USED THE
WORD "TREASON."
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS IN
THE DOMAIN, THEY ARE PRETTY
DAMNING.
>> Sean: THAT'S IT?
THE EVIDENCE OF THE PUBLIC --
YOU HAVE NO EVIDENCE.
SCHIFF KNEW THE ENTIRE TIME
WILL WAS NO COLLUSION.
YET HE WENT ON TV, SOME 250
TIMES, SINCE THE INAUGURATION
AND LIED HIS FACE OFF.
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF IS THE
EPITOME OF THE LEFT WING
PARTISAN HACK.
THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA, LIKE WE
HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU, HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE REPUBLICANS
ARE FINDING OUT WELL HE DID
NOTHING TO STOP RUSSIAN
ELECTION INTERFERENCE.
NOW CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES,
HE STARTED WARNING THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA ABOUT RUSSIAN
AND ELECTION INTERFERENCE IN
2014.
OBAMA IGNORED EVERY SINGLE
WARNING SIGN.
HERE IS THE HEADLINE FROM
NUNES, OP-ED HE WROTE IN THE
"WASHINGTON TIMES" AND HE
WRITES THE BEAR OUT THERE.
OKAY.
THAT MEANS RUSSIA.
THE HOUSE INTEL CHAIR GOES ON
TO DETAIL THE DIRECT THREAT
POSED BY PUTIN AND THE
RUSSIANS.
THIS IS 2014.
WHAT IS WORSE, WHILE THE
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE WAS
BEGINNING TO HAPPEN AND WAS
HAPPENING, OBAMA JUST BEFORE
THE ELECTION TRIED TO SHAME
THEN CANDIDATE DONALD TRUMP,
TELLING HIM TO STOP WHINING
ABOUT AN ELECTION POSSIBLY
BEING RIGGED BECAUSE THAT
COULD NEVER HAPPEN.
REMEMBER THIS?
>> THERE IS NO SERIOUS PERSON
OUT THERE WHO WOULD SUGGEST
THAT YOU COULD EVEN RIG
AMERICA'S ELECTIONS.
IN PART BECAUSE THEY ARE SO
DECENTRALIZED.
AND THE NUMBERS OF VOTES
INVOLVED.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THAT
HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST OR
THAT THERE ARE INSTANCES IN
WHICH IT WILL HAPPEN THIS
TIME.
I'D ADVISE MR. TRUMP TO STOP
WHINING AND TRY TO MAKE A CASE
TO GET VOTES.
>> Sean: NO SERIOUS PERSON
COULD EVER BELIEVE IT.
UNTIL HILLARY LOST AND YOU
NEEDED A BIG EXCUSE.
THEN WE'LL BELIEVE IT.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES TONIGHT.
ALL OF THIS NEW INFORMATION IS
REVEALING WHAT THEY REALLY,
REALLY ARE ALL ABOUT.
TOTAL FRAUDS, PARTISAN HACKS.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THEY PUT
THE COUNTRY THROUGH FOR WHAT?
18 MONTHS NOW.
DEMOCRATS HAD THE OPPORTUNITY,
OBAMA HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STOP RUSSIA.
AND THEN AFTER THEIR CANDIDATE
LOST, OH, IT COULDN'T HAPPEN
BUT IT DID HAPPEN.
THEN IT WAS ABOUT
DELEGITIMIZING AND SMEARING
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO DIVERT
ATTENTION AWAY FROM WHAT
REALLY HAPPEN EVEN THOUGH
OBAMA SAID IT COULD NEVER
HAPPEN.
THE TRUTH IS ALL COMING OUT.
THIS IS ONLY THE START.
I TOLD YOU THIS WAS THE YEAR
OF THE BOOMERANG.
THERE IS A LOT THAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
WE WILL STAY ON IT.
I WILL BE INVESTIGATED.
WE KNOW THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, WE KNOW THEY
WERE UNMASKING MEMBERS OF THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AT AN
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL.
OF COURSE, TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATES.
THEN, OF COURSE, AS THE TRUMP
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER.
WE STILL NEED TO GET TO THE
TRUTH ON THAT.
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T CARE
ABOUT PAYING FOR FALSE
INFORMATION, RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT LIES TO INFLUENCE
AN ELECTION.
THE F.B.I. TOOK THAT
THEY HAVE A LEGAL AND AN
ETHICAL AND PROTOCOL
OBLIGATION TO DO IT
THEMSELVES.
THEY LIED TO A FISA JUDGE.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED OR
CORROBORATED OR TOLD THE JUDGE
THAT CLINTON PAID IT.
REMEMBER THE GRASSILY-GRAHAM
MEMO, THE DOSSIER THAT MADE UP
THE BULK OF THE FISA
APPLICATION.
THE FORMER ASSISTANT F.B.I.
DIRECTOR TESTIFIED NO DOSSIER,
THERE WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN A
FISA APPLICATION.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED.
THEY NEVER CHECKED.
THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER SCANDAL IN THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY.
THE BIGGEST CORRUPTION SCANDAL